do here is jordan versus saudi arabia
let's get into it yeah also ling's been
a been one of those characters that's
been um i guess strong and a
strong character and potentially like
potential
tournament winning character from season
from even pre-release i think
and so
i think you had to have some kind of
idea of the match up
just from in general
well let's see how luffy decides to play
this one man
okay nice little
gonna parry towards the wall
and he's oh there you go using that aop
it was quite a basic on the back one
yeah oh big oh my god look at the chunk
that is a good that is pineapple chunks
and i cannot wait to get home because i
got some pineapple chunks
the pineapple chunks and sweet syrup
sweet serve the sweetest of the syrups
so you know you used to say this
probably that that paul is the
businessman he gets the business done
you know he's a nine-to-five guy clocks
out as soon as five hits bro he's not
doing that over time he wants to get
that job done
over time no look at this demo man
oh boy all the time you're very strong
that's dead wow luffy now with a
confidence this is what this is what
we're more used to seeing from luffy
right definitely
nice i like that stuff maybe standard
free's a good art size you know it looks
like it's got a really low um
hitbox yeah
he's using it a lot just to like you
know keep laying out and i guess it
would be the aop as well so it's an
option that he's using here very well
and he's got a massive likely look at
that i've seen it again oh that was a
that was a cheeky um death fist he was
that i'm saying he went to clock out bro
he's like it's 4 59.
i need to clock this out right now i
need to get out of here
let's see if we can get out of here
right now 30 seconds left in the clock
no break on that back 10 throw okay nice
patience there to get up correctly
oh you could have let it rip yeah that
could have been big damage there
okay a little bit slow
but i guess luffy's in a good position
where link is not in rage um territory
like rage yet yeah yeah
just outside of rage and they didn't
make it so that you know you have to
have
less life to get into rage and look at
that five seconds left on the clock the
rage drive gets punished with this
standing three again and you just see
that opposite it looks like it has a
little bit of tracking just to the right
which is perfect for aop so i feel like
that is the anti-aop move which uh he's
using really well as keypad versus ling
he def like i said he knows the match up
he knows what he needs to do his options
and on the on the flip side with the
pressure that luffy's been applying
there were opportunities for muhammad to
get the the launches with the death
place and other big whiffs but he wasn't
taking them that's what happens when you
get flustered yeah um so before the
match start we're just talking about
like
luffy needs to know the key moves to
using sling and i was i said thought
about down one but no it seems like
standing three you know you can see if
it hits as well you can go into three
two so even more damage there and i
think yeah that one here it is quite
advantageous like it's definitely your
goal again um i think it's really high
numbers
so um
lucky it looks like he's done his
homework he knows what to do and
it's really showing he's looking
comfortable and ling is a character once
you're uncomfortable she starts getting
into her mix up her smick stops and
hitting you with those lows and you're
uncomfortable it's long for man let's
just say it we'll keep it london it's
just long yeah there's a lot of a man
yeah definitely we've seen it as well
with people like mr cotton europe
terrorizing icfc with that link
especially when they get started with
all the all the dancing all the flippy
floppies and spinneys you know it's just
crazy but look at that no no no flippy
floppies anymore he's going straight to
the horrung you know knowing that luffy
was just too comfortable versus the lane
not letting him get anything started and
now we're gonna potentially get another
type of vortex you know the horung
strings
are we gonna get them heavy on the
infinite as your two are gonna be the
most beautiful stage in tekken have you
got added in season two let's go yeah
actually this is a fun fact this this
actually wasn't season one but you have
to have the vr i'm sure i had a video
yes
i remember when you went uh you invited
me to the namco yeah in the uk and i was
able to try out the vr i'm like wow this
is cool and it was this stage i'm sure
it was it was yeah see people may not
know that taught you a little something
this stage was actually there from
before
that's crazy i don't even think about
that but have you got luffy nice down
four two that muhammad can probably get
something started but no walls are in
play okay okay he's
he may not be playing ling but the
mix-ups are still strong
oh boy oh boy no no duck yeah that's how
you could have ducked that there it's
back he's gonna get oh i thought he's
gonna run all the way in is he gonna run
a little bit oh oh oh oh oh i lost my
breath
i couldn't breathe
i couldn't breathe why
he that was such a bait he put the the
worm on the hook he reeled it out there
and just left it that he ran straight in
thinking you're getting um a blockable
charge but then you use this power crush
then no bro i'm poor i'm clocking out
it's five i'm going yeah
none of this no break of the throw okay
here we go i'm liking this the this one
yeah hold on
oh nice big car here it's gonna be
chunky damage
okay close to the demo man
rage available now oh god try to go to
the power crush oh
luffy is just looking so on point
are you serious magic four back one two
look at this from luffy blues box he is
definitely feeling himself right now
he's comfortable he looks comfortable
now
yeah okay but as i say that gets a big
car here
yeah
nice nice combo okay nice it gets a
little bit momentum
reminisce in his chin
yeah he's got the jail facades but luffy
just poking away in his face now gets a
life lead backing off a little bit
trying to keep hold of it very back and
forth right now luffy one hit away
potentially
nice
that move is so good
it's scary as well because you could be
pressing buttons and you know you're
gonna get hit because it it absorbs
absorbs your moves
absolutely and you're trying to go for
the side step moves on it's homing so
luffy now again with a lot of momentum
trying to finish this early
nice time in the downfall too there gets
the full launch
yep okay what's the mix up oh oh my big
whiff on the top could have launched
yeah that was optimal back free
okay nice punish
oh
that could be dead with the rage can he
finish it though
nice
yes nice
wow no way just like that
every single time luffy is like so close
to winning muhammad mishma brings it
back with a horror can he finish it now
and take it to a final match i hope it's
not going to be like one of them meme
videos where someone's like running the
100 meter hurdles and they just chop at
the last hurdle over there in the league
oh no
mohammed bishop with the momentum now
but you can never count paul out man
paul has so much damage potential
he can always bring him back nice block
on the law seems like he has a good ring
now a little bit slow on that launch and
punish with the duck
jabs oh no he's in the vortex now
we've got rage available nice dark
ladies and lads mohammed mishima with
the reverse sweep is gonna take you to a
final match luffy
is he going to be eliminated hitting the
loser bracket and go home with fifth
bobby from jordan muhammad mishima a
switch to the horror from link no like
um i did this was unexpected i i didn't
know he played harang
um and it looked like it was um curtains
it looked like you know luffy had
control of that match as well but
all of a sudden like i said but the
reverse sweep um
seems like he's he's settled a bit now
you know that's definitely going to
settle him he's got some momentum he's
broken that you know it was tournament
point he was playing i'm not talking one
point so i set point he was he was that
was tournament his tournament live and
it seemed like he just got that power up
he seemed like he had the right answers
and he just took took the match back
again so hold on you know paul you're
doing some overtime today mate yeah this
is this look
jordan was supposed to have a master
event in 2020 before this little virus
came along and did his thing right and
you know jordan having having a look at
them with the fake invitational
everybody could see the pakistanis the
koreans everyone that was there could
see just how strong this community was
for such a small scene 20 people i was
talking to these guys when i was there
they said we you know i was seeing it
consists of about 20 people and but we
are coming we're committed we're
passionate and we love this game so much
that we just we meet up all the time
when we play and we just grind out the
game this is why these guys are so
strong right and
and it's great to see that these guys
are competing right now going up against
i'll give you one of the best one of the
best players in the world with luffy and
he's taking it to a final match with not
even his main character so here we go
jordan versus saudi arabia let's go
horan versus paul
what did that say he blocked the low and
it looked like this um the ice kicks
with i wonder that's a specific match up
thing
maybe we'll see maybe luffy will take
that um into consideration earlier but
as i said that gets hit with a down four
two gets caught stepping
yeah i think luffy is in a bit of
autopilot mode right now he was
sidestepping into a button and he got
caught but have you gone out a big
opportunity for damage yeah against the
wall oh god this is going to do
so much damage that new wall ended up
from pools it does chunks again on the
back of the head
um
nice doesn't bite that time that's one
of those moves like you get caught by it
more often um than you should
yeah
i like that it's a good call out from
luffy to know that muhammad was going to
go for a move at the start of the round
sometimes very very easy way to open up
your opponent just notice to see if
they'd like to press buttons at the
start of the round easy back dash into
launch
yeah nice sidewalk oh that's a great
conversion on the combo but was it it
looked a little bit funky
a lot of pressure and that should be it
now yeah so this is this is a very
peculiar situation here because this is
what happened last time
luffy was very comfortable had the two
rounds and then mohammed mishima just
literally just got the power up
yeah this is where he started to wake up
man but look at some loopy character
specialists he knows all the situations
nice adaptation and a wall to his back a
breakable wall not a place you want to
be in nice downforce to keep up though
muhammad michelle he's bringing it back
again bob z
okay my horror is going the wrong way
you know oh do a u-turn mate
okay nice
oh
it gets the next one
is this gonna be it look at damage plus
frames and again
nice down four that was actually kind of
scary he needed to take back the
momentum because it's one of the
technical techniques
it's not just a fighting game played on
the pad it is also a mental game now he
he's seen
that happen before but you know talking
about seeing it happen